let's go
all right all right all right a few
minutes
away from start time logiclivechest.com
live i'm live
prep my openings done everything i could
for this baby done everything i could
i'm excited i'm excited i'm excited i'm
excited this has been my whole life my
cousin has called me every day on the
phone and i
i always forget to call back because i'm
just busy doing chess
every goddamn day i can't in a way wait
for it to be over
but there's only two ways for it to end
and it's winning or losing and the
latter does not sound fun
and i'd rather do something fun and the
words of mango people pog out that [ __ ]
don't know if it applies here but it is
fun to say
it is wise words wisdom
wisdom wisdom wisdom i did play rocket
league earlier today hikaru
roasted me for this apparently it's true
i did spend my morning playing rocket
league against atriac
in a show match for a thousand two
hundred fifty dollars
where i won uh in absolute
stomping fashion game one twelve to one
which just so you guys know is a record
for atrialk
it is the biggest blowout ever um so
everybody clap for atrialk
really impressive stuff out there games
two and three were tighter
i have to give him credit he brought it
close
he doesn't know however that i decided
to not use the jump button for all of
game three or the boost button for all
of game two
he did not know that which i think um if
he did know he wouldn't feel so
but we won't bring it up to him that's a
secret that's a secret amongst us
all right just.com you guys you got to
keep this secret don't tell a triage
it's going to hurt his feelings
anyway
let's just [ __ ] do our best today
played like four games this morning
did good i don't like to play before my
game like to take a couple hours off
i walked around i wasn't too hungry i
got a case of the the nervous yawns
which i didn't know it was a thing until
this tournament which was cool
um but yeah we'll just uh we'll just
come out
i can't wait till
18 months from now
[Music]
when they tell the legends of two
soldiers
who took the battlefield
one a little more active
right behind every step of the way
[Music]
but there has to be a loser
and it could be me and i think thousands
would rejoice
but hear me out
it would be kind of funny
just a little bit if someone as
brain dead as me what a [ __ ]
chess tournament so i put all
faculties in all resources in
all of robert has his knowledge magnus
carlson's
looks and now
bobby hall
eat [ __ ] i'm coming
we got this
[Music]
i cut my nails for this better tactility
i shaved my unibrow but i decided not to
shave this
it's my playoff beard
sorry to any nhl fans it's uh
surely not as nordic as you come to
expect
[Music]
all right we're starting soon boys i'm
gonna close out
keep it going
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah baby that's what i've been waiting
for that's what it's all about
magic time
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pug champs three presented by grip six
levy rosman hikaru nakamura we're here
to swap in for that amazing coverage
earlier by alexander botez
and anna kremling hicaro were you
watching what were your impressions of
those matches
yeah so it's great to be back doing
doing commentary after a couple of days
the match has been really really close
so far i think today for example this
match between
rubius and nico extremely close it came
down to an armageddon game
um also the previous match between
charlie and rayne wilson
really really close charlie had great
opportunities to win the second game and
force a tiebreaker uh he wasn't able to
do it
kind of nerves got him at the last
moment but nonetheless i think all the
matches have been very very competitive
so far and i'm really
looking forward to this next match
between logic and
ludwig it should be uh very exciting as
well yes
let's show everybody the format once
again before we just kind of
cut the chatter uh it's uh well
at this point it's a single elimination
uh the players play two games
but the one difference is that if it's
tied one to one as we saw earlier it's a
five minute per player game
if that ends in a draw they swap the
colors but the higher seed
gets the white pieces so if this next
match goes to
that playoff ludwig will start with the
white pieces um
let's also just remind everybody what
we're what we're all about here uh
we have a community outreach goal if
you've been a returning
audience member you know what that's all
about whatever place a player finishes
in as we get that donation there there
thank you for the ten dollar donation we
are matching up to a hundred thousand
dollars as part of chess.com
community outreach initiative you all
know what to do there's a donation
button under the player
let's try to cross that 20k mark maybe
hit 21 22k over the course of the
broadcast
and then let's just remind everybody who
is playing who today
hicaro this first matchup ludwig logic i
don't know who to pick man i have like a
slight inkling for
ludwig given his experience like right
he just survived that tense
playoff versus moist critical but
logic's been great man
hasn't he he's played great chess yeah
so i think this match
it could go either way i don't think
there's a clear favorite again like you
i would say
ludwig is probably the very slight
favorite simply because he's had
experience he played in pogchamps one
he was in the final match of the
consolation bracket where he lost to
charlie so i think the experience of
anything
tilts the match a little bit in his
favor but again logic has been playing a
lot of chess he played very well against
rayne wilson extremely impressive in
that final match in the group stage
so i think that uh anything could happen
yeah i am uh just
looking to see if the players
get started here
all right so here we go oh
what's going on
i think i'm gonna i think i'm gonna make
a prediction uh okay
trying to figure out who i'm gonna bet
on i've made it better i've made bets on
on ludwig
every every time so far so i think i'm
gonna make a bet on uh
on on ludwig i'm gonna i'm gonna bet um
i am gonna bet 33
333 points on ludwig
i the screen sharing software that i use
to access the games i think just booted
me out so
i'm going to have to reboot it because
all right that's never happened before
fantastic so
all right let me find a way to well
uh production team let's cut it to uh
someone else and then i will uh
the game is stored by the way it is a um
it is it is a scotch opening
so ludwig correctly plays i believe
lotto is white right yeah so he
correctly plays bishop to e3 does not
play c3 like xqc did against uh
moist critical in the previous match
where he played with c3 queen f6 knight
takes c6 queen takes off to checkmate
uh plays bishop to e3 which i think he
is prepared
there we go we're back perfect see we
gotta we we
we wire in i don't know if that's the
right word the hosts
and i uh my you know producer shout out
to uh to aaron was like yo what are you
doing and i was like uh i thought i was
ready
but it looks like i was not oh logic
blunders on my uh
oh no yeah and as i was saying that our
screen sharing software caught up uh
we've got a blunder oh man
this is bad oh yikes
and this is i think the big danger i
think um is the opening fees when i've
seen several of these players like um
logic and xqc in particular i feel like
both of them are very talented players
once they get out of the opening phase
of the game but in the opening phase
if they get into trouble they can end up
too far behind to come back
and i think so far very unfortunate
start for uh for logic and i think
ludwig should win this game he's up a
juicer already he's got two bishops in
the night against the fishermen tonight
smooth sailing if he takes care of
business
yeah that's so that's so frustrating
because
as you said this bishop c5 is a good
it's a good line i mean it's
it's i don't know if it's the main line
at the top level knight f6 is also quite
good but
when you get this black has to know
queen f6 that's actually
yeah i mean queen f6 or even bishop to
b6 but just understand the idea that
white can trade the knights on c6 and
take the bishop on c5
yep exactly and then there's also other
things that can happen with d6 you get
your pawns tripled but
um yeah so
um i mean very tough start i think
bishop d4
here if um if ludwig plays bishop d4
moves his other bishop gets his king out
of the board i think he's in great shape
to take the lead 1-0
do you think well no actually i i was
going to say wow
good move from from ludwig yeah very
good move
the nerves i think what really hurt
charlie
was maybe the fact that he was playing
uh
ring wilson i think that's what really
hurt him because
ludwig doesn't feel like he's up against
some sort of titan he just feels like
he's playing a guy that you know he can
beat
maybe that hurt charlie that he's
playing this you know colossal type i
mean i think there's something else that
should be said though which i think is
based on the way the pairings occurred
and the first matchup where rayne played
against michelle carr i think we
actually
thought that rayne was better than he
than he is because of the disparity in
the ratings so i think because he won
that match so convincingly
um people sort of assume that he's sort
of a ringer you don't have much
information on him but in fact when he
played charlie he made many mistakes in
the in the games today so
i think it's also something
psychological or psychological where
because he played against
michelle in the first match everyone's
like oh no he's really strong he's
really really dangerous
and um i think that made a big
difference
i'm just drawing arrows one of my arrows
has been played okay i'm not do you like
this move i mean i just simplifying as
long as he stabilizes like rook v8 could
be annoying
you know there's tactics rook b2 yeah i
love c5 i think for ludwig it's great to
trade uh now it's a critical moment
probably the last critical moment i
would say the game where logic can maybe
come back
because if uh if ludwig is able to
develop the bishop and castle the king
or move the queen and castle the king
and avoid getting into trouble here
he should win the game
trying to figure out exactly what ludwig
is thinking because if he gets too
aggressive with knight d5 queen b2 all
of a sudden and
um so do we have uh
cams on ludwig yet we do we do yep
[Music]
he's not saying anything but we got good
[Music]
[Music]
music
that's a solid move but let's see if
this is not bad
i just think that this threat although
met with this
is results in a pretty fierce group here
which i don't know if necessarily is
that bad for me if i'm castling kingside
but
i think normally in games especially
around my level
the b2 g2 b7 g7 pawns
are oftentimes captured by the queen and
that can be make or break for either
side for the capturer
or the uh the defender and
why enter a situation like that when i
can just play a normal developing move
perfect spot on yeah well
having said that now logic can play roof
b8 and then it's very tough to see rook
b1 rook b2
uh if logic plays this move
you know ludwig okay he plays queen g6
so not a bad move
yeah there is this
there is i think i think ludwig can just
castle here and on bishop h3 play queen
of three so yeah if ludwig sees queen f3
then he's going to be doing uh
he's he's probably gonna win the game i
think
as long as he doesn't get spooked he uh
i was trying to find exactly what he
said about logic there was one of the
first or second days of pogchamps where
we gave him the big stage because we
know ludwig's gonna
provide us with good content okay g3
it's a move it's not the best move there
are some issues now potentially for
white but it still looks like
ludwig is doing very well
yeah now we need this that
we need that move or else it's it's bad
news you would love to go f5 but
that would that's right i would actually
think king h8 and f5 is one of the
one of the best opportunities here for
black to try and get back in the game
because the only issue that white has is
if he castles the king to the king side
there's no bishop inside the sniper's
nest so it's a it's a very open
light square diagonal and benji fishy
got into trouble as well when he hit an
open diagonal like that yesterday
against daniel negranu so
that's the one big hope for logic here
so definitely not something like bishop
e6 by the way because
even though you open up your rook you
don't need to leave
white with the only piece on the board
that is a knight or a bishop you've got
to
know some bishops you forget played good
move good move by logic
and again i mean it's it's obviously
winning for white with correct play but
it's still
if you're ludwig you're a little bit
concerned because i think ludwig really
wants to castle
uh king side and i think he's probably a
little bit nervous to push the f pawn
here
yeah exactly f3 is probably one of the
best moves he might also play bishop
back to e2
that would be a great move also
yeah bishop e2 just trades the bishop i
th the worry is that he plays queen d2
okay plays f3 after is good yeah it's
also good yeah queen d2 would have been
bad because of bishop f3
and now i have a bad feeling the logic
is
okay okay that's a good move bishop is a
great move now the question here is will
ludwig see the castle queen side
and he does actually see it which is
which is important so it goes queen e3
i think if ludwig can get his king
castles at king's side he's very likely
going to win this match
that's what i would say the worst part
is
with black it's like you don't want the
double pawns because you'd rather have
a6 b5
and an attack right but yeah the double
pawns really make it hard for black to
attack and based on the texture of where
the pawns are
um i think it's going to be very hard
for logic to create counter play here i
think ludwig is looking really really
good in this position
yeah he i mean it's certainly very good
with such an early blunder i guess you
just
i mean i scotch was the first opening i
ever learned and
the amount of people i caught with
knight takes c6 is uh you know
it happens to you once and then
hopefully it never happens again right
exactly yeah so i mean it's it's an
important tactic and i think that's
i would have suggested that logic played
bishop b6 there that would have been the
move that i i would have shown him um
i don't know who he's been studying with
though to be fair so it's hard to be
critical at all
and now ludwig gets castled and unless
logic can play f5 at some point
i think what was going to win this game
yeah now it's really difficult
it's i mean at this point your your next
strategy is
be as solid as possible and try to get
up on time but ludwig's even got a
two-minute advantage
uh yeah ludwig is just crushing it right
now he's got a great position
again the texture of where the plate
pieces are placed makes it very hard for
black to do anything here no pawn breaks
can't the pawns are double so you have
no b5 to attack the bishops the bishop
on c4 is kind of planted
um i think i think white's white's doing
very very well i think ludwig should win
this game i really don't see where the
counter play is going to be coming from
threat's now gone
okay he's going for this pawn he seems
confident she's
completely defended at the moment but if
i didn't move
then that's a threat exactly no he sees
it so that's that's what he's looking at
here
so if i do move my night which is
tempting then he's gonna [ __ ] my [ __ ] up
um which is totally reasonable um that's
like i don't know that's the
professional way of saying something
[ __ ] up i will push this guy right
here
now we're very tight and now i can make
a move like this
next turn uh threatening the queen and
this pawn yeah
he misses he's missing queen a1 that's
the danger he's missing
queen all the way down and he's lucky
it's not mate i mean imagine queen a1
was made
right i think also for la for uh for
ludwig he's got to be careful because
maybe black can go c6 and d5 now
somewhere to try and open up the center
um again i think i think i mean whether
if logic finds c6 it's very unlikely but
maybe
oh c6 is yeah of course that would be
very nice but you've also got to be
thinking you know
he wants to play knight d5 and so i have
to play season but of course
that would be a trap man hey queen d6
queen c3 wow oh
wow whoa c6 is a great move here by um
absolutely fantastic move by by logic
now it's a little bit scary now and i
would definitely be concerned
yeah that's a great move now ludwig has
to see queen d6 queen c3
yeah a lot that's a great move by logic
and now the problem is that d5 is a big
idea with
pontics pawn takes a knight takes queen
a1 and black is a very clear-cut idea
push the pawn in the center open up the
diagonal to a1 that's why i really
didn't like uh
that's why i really didn't like this uh
this idea with b3
from woodwork yeah a5a4 i mean i
have some feeling a5 and ludwig himself
might go a4 but then
you know bring the bishop back and but
logic also
can play bishop g2 he might you know
pick apart the pawns and if you get one
pawn then you get a second pawn
right right so my my guess here is
probably
the best move is king king b1 is the
safest most practical move that
that ludwig can play plays rookie three
i don't i don't dislike it
uh again the dangerous black will go
work d8 and push d5 at some moment
though
yes the logic should say that rookie
three protects the knight so white can
take the pawn on d6
yes because you go why did he go rookie
three because you're looking oh queen d6
i have queens and then you have to go oh
i see okay and then right exactly yeah
yeah
another thing i guess white plays rookie
three like black should play rook d8
because you you both move rooks is white
at any point threatening some g4
and trapping this bishop maybe yeah i
think g4 is always a is always an idea
here i think logic has to go rook d and
after g4
ludwig is completely winning because the
bishop is out to lunch on the side of
the board
um probably it eventually it's just
doing nothing useful it's just on the
wrong side of the board
so if um if ludwig sees g4 after work to
d8 i think ludwig will win this game
but but in general logic has to go rook
d8 it is the only move here where there
are chances to keep the game
game alive ludwig almost up
double on the clock so 30 seconds more
go by
and um logic is going to be down three
to six
which obviously also is not in his favor
he's got to go all in
yeah he has to play rook d8 here he has
to it's the it's the only move
can he play queen h6 that would be okay
i would have liked the other work to dh
just because at some point maybe you
want to keep the file open
although here you can also go rookie 8
and then d5 so
he does find rook d8 which is important
yeah if he spots this pin as well like
he can really start putting some ideas
together here but
right so i guess i mean
it's all in ludwig if ludwig finds a
couple of very good moves he's going to
win the game without a doubt
um it's like he's trying to set up e5
this pawn push but then pawn takes and
your queen is under attack
something important to note perhaps
worth putting my king b2
soft very soft move wise
but since there's no dark squared bishop
it's pretty
sound yes not the worst idea ever but
you are in the
face of the pins so and like right now
this is like kind of like
it's like when i watch like better
people play chess
where we are just improving our position
but we have no real
actual breaks happening until just
then yeah that huh i just wish though
because if okay so takes
takes takes
man he's so lucky queen a1 is not just
made right
sure i don't think i'm missing anything
oh man
well he might see it now right before he
does it if we just pull this up like
whoa the bishop f5 is a really sneaky
move
yeah wow that's a very sneaky move by um
by logic look at that he he notices the
change in the position
and he he's man i would love it if black
had these b and d
rooks that would be oh man
oh no oh no oh my god
no way pontics pond come on logic take
the juicer
no way logic might be playing this in a
tricky way like he's maintaining the
pressure on d5 but he
if he takes knight d5 he'll spot queen
a1 it check me yeah
you just got to go just take the pawn
what's he thinking about like i said i
have a feeling
he he he wanted to like trick a little
bit with this pawn but now he has to
realize that taking
he has this chance because what logic
did there sorry what ludwig did there on
the last move is he he's cut his king's
escape
right exactly yeah
he's just it's the only movement
position here he's got no time he's just
got to do it
and then of course white will play
bishop takes and uh
ah i don't like eh6 here because now
ludwig
should move his king 100 should move his
king yes d6 is a good move but not
realistic
at this level um but he's got to move
the king here just king b1 or king b2
one of the two moves
even rookie five action is very good
yeah he did have it in his plans to play
king b2 i don't know if logic ended up
seeing that queen a1 uh
keep saying both of their names for the
other person i don't think ludwig
saw that after knight d5 there was queen
a1 but
oh he hung me oh oh no
oh my god
[Music]
oh he's a god oh
he hasn't he had no idea he's a god
what a god that is heartbreaking
oh my god no i mean it wasn't it wasn't
a godly move i mean he just he
maintained the tension
there ludwig carl ludwig had tunnel
vision on the night move so he just did
it
but he didn't oh my gosh
crazy oh that is heartbreaking
yeah because you know how much prep went
into the opening there ludwig's
ludwig prepared that opening he got
everything he wanted he got the trick he
got the piece
and then he just hung queen a1 man
crazy absolutely crazy oh that is
absolutely heartbreaking
i mean that was like the one in a
hundred the one
shot and a lot and ludwig just kept
missing it like even in politics he kept
thinking he could take like
if he just kept his queen any bishop 5
was such a great move because
if if the queen was any other square it
was never checkmate
yep and it forced the queen back and
yeah we got to ask logic if he set that
up somehow if he was envisioning it i
apologize
uh but okay i mean probably he just saw
the idea that if he could get the queen
there it was made he probably didn't
really conceptualize everything else but
i'm sure he was aware that the queen got
there it's mate
um but yeah there you have it that's
crazy
favorite player just like magnus did
every day against wesley so in the last
term he played
well on that note uh ludwig is gonna
have to uh
lick his wounds and he's gonna have to
take that confidence that he got from
this opening into the next game because
logic has the white pieces he's gonna
start with e4
we'll see if ludwig goes back to the
scandinavian uh which he played against
moist
or if he goes back to what he always
plays but we'll be right back with the
second round of today park champs three
presented by grip six don't go anywhere
in a game where uh very clearly
um yeah chess.com if you aren't
updated i i just choked a game um shout
out to
hess for uh for being nice uh and magnus
for the wise tip of playing king b1
king b1 or king b8 or b8 i guess is this
way
which makes a lot of sense i thought to
do this earlier and
if i had done that i would have been
fine too
both would have been fine i should have
played that move i guess i did not need
to play as forcing of a move as knight
but i thought i didn't need to play it
because i was going to move this knight
and if i'm going to move the knight then
why would i go here but then the obvious
response is well then that's why you go
b1
and don't waste a turn going b2 but
anyway what are some positive takeaways
well i was up on the clock and
i was winning in the opening so i don't
think he has much opening prep
uh and as long as i don't [ __ ] up like
that again i feel good about game two
and i feel really good about a 5-0
but did you see the the life vanish from
my face
i was so um concerned with the bishops
or the night safety
that i didn't think well the knight is
serving a role here which is protecting
a checkmate because this queen here
which has to be here because he made he
actually made a lot of good moves that
that made this happen right because my
queen wasn't here i was totally safe
but then this move which may be a better
response
at this point would have been this
and then maybe he just goes for the
check anyway
yeah but it's all right
whatever man it's a chess game
on to game two just as hard
i think the good news is i know the
scotch a lot better
which means i probably know
this opening a little better
and if i win game two then game three
will be
my pick of color and i think the scotch
is pretty easy
on a guy who doesn't really know how to
play the scotch but
we gotta win game two i could just go
out o2 a buster
which would be kind of funny
chess is the ultimate game of each [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no matter where you are
[Music]
[ __ ]
too slow too slow i played really well
i'm happy with how i played outside of a
game ending blunder
[Music]
but all the greats have had game ending
blunders
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by group 6 a
friendly reminder which we uh tell you
about
feels like whenever i'm doing commentary
and then also whenever i'm spectating
right at this exact moment
you can play all of the bot versions of
these players
uh if that last game gives you any
confidence go get
ludwig bot he'll probably hang main one
um and uh
at this point he's gotta he's gotta win
there is no more
time for yeah i mean it's it's very
tough for ludwig the good thing for
ludwig again is he's
played in pog champs one um so because
he played a pogchamps one i think he
did he lose uh he lost him he lost the
first game i think to somebody in the
bracket station he came back to win if
i'm not mistaken i don't remember
against who
but i think he had he was in the same
situation so i think for sure
um i think for sure anything can happen
here i think also the fact that he got
such a winning position
gives him great chances um and you have
a lot of confidence
it was just one it was basically one
idea that he missed that's all it was
yes he also lost the first game to moist
critical
so we can't forget like he right
he won the game with white and then he
took that momentum
uh into the armageddon and played white
again
and his hit but now he he lost with
white he just lost with white
so he's clearly been doing some work on
his openings
clearly um i don't know if he's gonna
trot out the same scandinavian he did
play the scandinavian defense against
moist
yeah i don't know what his his opening
choice will be i think um
i think in general he's just got he just
gotta just play good moves just just
focus take a deep breath and try to play
good moves but the one thing i will say
about ludwig having seen him play a lot
of chess on stream is he definitely you
can tell
he's a little bit shocked like he
doesn't he's like
shocked by what happened in that game
you can tell he's focused but i think he
really is in shock
um and so it's going to be interesting
to see how he controls himself i think
you know in charlie's case
earlier today charlie was fortunate that
he got a great position in the second
game
so because charlie was able to get the
free flow in the second game he's able
to just blitz
out moves and get a good position the
nerves and like sort of the tilt factor
didn't really matter in the same way
that that in this case ludwig being
black it's probably gonna be harder to
get to like move 10
just on moves alone ludwig by the way
has
played uh the queen d6 scandinavian so
if anybody wants a very easy opening to
to play get get that scandinavian and uh
play this so someone's done some videos
on i feel like
someone oh wait but you you recommended
queen a5 right lovey no i
i i talk a little bit about everything
but thank you for plugging me yeah
that's uh great great see
we're like volleyball you know but but
will he play
asic okay he clearly has done his breath
isn't this exactly
his game against charlie was this exact
opening but i think charlie went bishop
e2 and so he didn't go b5
but in this case logic did put the
bishop on c4 so he did play b5
which is very good yes yes b5 does get
played and
and i wonder if you know he's going to
play bishop b7 and then e6 or what he's
going to do
the thing about queen d6 scandinavian in
case anybody in chat wants to know
uh g3 is the way to play this with
bishop f4 and bishop here and
i mean people just don't know that and
black can get a very good position so
it's one way
you can also play it the way that that
um that logic played it but not d3 where
you go d4
and then you play for castles in an
early rookie one with knight g5 that's
also very very strong as well yes
yes um but but i think it's also it's
harder because
somehow i feel like when the queen is on
d6 it looks kind of scary like i i mean
it looks like the queen is just like
it's it's
really near your bishop i think and it
just it looks scary optically
so oh no oh look oh my gosh logic just
j logic just gambits a bishop to start
this game too
oh wow okay yo what is this guys guys
is this does logic think he can think
he's bobby fischer or something he can
spot his opponent an extra bishop every
game
that maybe i mean if ludwig's gotta win
now i
i oh come on come on
what's he saying i want to hear this i'm
up an entire piece
you go for it man you do you
i feel you bro but i'm just gonna go d8
man
i don't got to get custom you made this
easy on me
i play fiance
maybe play a move like knight over here
then if he keeps this here trade take
trade okay
all right all good just a lot just get
your [ __ ] going queen moves
he's got a good strat he wants to trade
the queen he won't there won't be any
long queen moves
and uh no he's right what he's doing
it's good now there is a threat
here i think he'll probably bring out
his bishop
if i know anything about logic but i'm
gonna go for this
[Music]
yeah this i mean again what what oh
knight c5 is a good move though by logic
yeah great move great move i mean i
expect bishop c6
this should be right then 95 and it
starts to get dicey again
yeah because then ludwig has to find
like you know e6 he has to not play f6
for example
f6 would lose the game
actually oh my god you're right
yeah there's no king d7 at the end like
bishop c695 f6 queen h5 g6926 and you're
getting mated
uh that would be so brutal no i mean you
just can't play f6 f6 is a move you just
you know you can't play but sometimes
when you play these matches
it all goes out the window it's like
when you sit down in school to take the
test you all that
studying you're like wait what then you
do something crazy so
yeah i mean again all i'm gonna say is
this it's all on
it's all on um it's all in ludwig he has
a peace advantage again in the second
game he's just got to um
he's just got to take care of business
he's up a piece now the problem though
is how is he developing his knight on b8
if white goes knight e5 that's actually
one of the big dangers
um yeah i was just saying ludwig has to
play e6 right
or even then there's only move after 95
that i would play
there's also knight d4 it doesn't sound
as good but
it's you know it's just in general
keeping the pressure up
i think logic will find knight e5 i i
kind of expect him to because
there are no other real developing moves
you can play the rook to e1 maybe
but yeah he plays it okay
i mean ludwig has to see that knight c6
is not a threat and then play
e6 and he might go queen d6
he might do that and then i think logic
will play d4
right it's the only move actually to
keep keep all the pieces on the board i
mean it's very very scary
if ludwig plays the e6 he's he's pretty
much out of the woods i think because
then his development with the bishop and
the king
will help him and he plays it very nice
close he cannot fall for the throbbing
checkmate with like queen f3 or queen h5
here he's got to make sure to go
g6 on queen h5 and if clean up three
just queen off six
yeah exactly just straight and the
benefit is that well logic might
forget about bishop f8 takes knight i'm
there is a chance he'll just
totally blank but um he also should not
take on c6 that's not why you move the
knight to e5
right you know i think d4 is the best
move here and the idea is to play queen
g4
following it up with bishop g5 at some
moment
and if the king castles you also have
bishop h6 like all this
annoying stuff because yeah i mean logic
is playing not to lose cons
considering he won the first game so one
and a half oh he's going for the big
cheese the big cheese
now if ludwig plays queen f6 here queens
are coming off the board
and there will be no excuse for him to
not win the game yeah he
he sees it one move he sees it
and he's trying to play f6 ooh
oh just go here hold up
this [ __ ] is playing
frustratingly
yeah he is you can just push
don't push don't just push push don't
push push
but if i push what changes in the
position well my king
is no longer protected so he goes
check nice he saw it yeah
perfect great everybody benefits he
yells a lot
he can take and then win the bit of the
rook
so that's not the best move there you go
in fact
how about we just make this really
obvious about what i want to have happen
good just play clean out six yeah
[Music]
oh he said queen here oh oh oh
yeah is that the the way that he worked
protect that
i don't know really good cheeky checks
the way that he worked that out
out um not to do the pun but the way
that he worked out the sequence i'm
gonna go for it was perfect
literally perfect the way that he worked
out the sequence
perfect queen f6 and absolutely perfect
that was uh that was super kept it very
clean yeah
and if ludwig doesn't win here i mean he
doesn't deserve to
you know to win the match i mean because
this one he's he's definitely got it
he's
got it going here queens have to come
off the board he's going to be way ahead
by at least one piece
so i mean this is this is it for ludwig
he's got he's got to uh
he's got he's got to get it done yeah
for logic to now come out of this
without losing any material he probably
has to like take the queen and then take
on c6 right
right and it's too limited just too
limited so i i think ludwig is gonna win
here
really i mean the thought process there
was absolutely brilliant by ludwig the
way that he worked out f6 is the queen
h5
queen e7 then realizing why don't i make
it really simple and really obvious and
now
logic just hangs a second juicer in the
middle of the board
yeah queen takes knight and um and then
ludwig is gonna coast to victory
yeah i like how uh ludwig's kind of
taking his time he he obviously saw
that the queens could get traded but now
he's going to pause and he he's just
drawn the arrow to the knight
yep and that's it she just takes it
that's game over
yeah he's looking at checks which we've
been threatening if it hadn't been
defended
right because then my king is in a lot
of trouble
and yeah perfect the way that the way
that ludwig is using this
reasoning it out here is really really
focused about it again
that's the case if they're playing at a
different level but i still still
feel like it's very easy to sort of lose
your mind and and panic after that first
game which is like
what happened like and you just kind of
want to move really fast but one was
being very slow very methodical and he's
really working it through
yeah like exactly he said f6 and a lot
of us just go f6
oh that looks pretty good never in the
history of chess having ever thrown
plus six
well but surely i could find out a way
to make it happen
[Music]
oh man it's like it's like those
basketball teams you know uh
let it be a lesson no one ever beats us
by more than 30
you know 29. so uh no he's got a point
he deserves
he deserves both games frankly but he
blundered that first one so
he just tunneled on one thing that's it
he would have won the first game
otherwise so this is it's very unusual i
think where you see
a match like this where someone i think
at least in the bracket stage someone's
been so dominant it feels like where
like this match should be 2-0
ludwig should win this game and he
clearly should have won the first game
but instead it's going to be 1-1 caro
there is like queen d4 bishop e3
take f takes with queen f7 i'm like
that's a very nasty trick yeah well i
i guess if i'm ludwig here i would i
would go queen of five personally
because you're ahead by a knight in a
bishop you just want to trade
just offer to offer to trade your queens
yeah he uh he has to find this balance
between being like okay my opponent is
completely tilted he's just losing and
giving me all his pieces one of those
pieces might be poisoned
so just keep it cool queen five easy
move
um he's drawing a lot of arrows i mean
he is
okay they're all gone now we don't we
don't need to go look but
and uh hikaru he uh he plays queen f5
look at that very nice move
yeah real i i think ludwig realizes that
he's ahead by a bishop and knight so it
doesn't matter you just want to make
sure queens and rooks come off the board
if you can
if you're gonna offer the trade so queen
five is the best move
and logic either has to trade queens
or play queen d3 or queen e2 and neither
of those moves are gonna get the job
done
so right yeah i think it's very likely
we're gonna have uh we're gonna have a
have a
five minute game for all the marbles
and ludwig gets white because okay again
yeah knight she fired okay now just swap
and that's all she wrote that's game
over
there is literally no way that ludwig is
going to lose this game
zero percent chance yeah and 94 is a
brilliant move too
nice again try to try to fossilize the
knight on f3 you're hitting the pawn on
c2
and 91 is the only move and and so yeah
we're gonna have it we're gonna have a
five minute game
gonna be really exciting such strange
games man i mean
ludwig i keep doing i don't know what it
is about both their names they just they
just roll off the tongue like in
an equivalent way um logic played
97 against rayne wilson in their first
game in the group stage so it's just
weird seeing him blunder early it's just
i it seems like it i i suspect there
there's some nerves but also probably he
hasn't studied these specific openings
i guess yeah bishop f3 just chops it
perfect just chop it all
off just offer the trades after takes i
would even just play bishop d6 frankly
just offer another trade of bishops just
reduce the material on the board
right because you know if you play like
bishop d6 and then takes takes on knight
c2
rook c1 and uh-oh uh-oh no but i mean
ludwig's gonna win this game let's let's
be serious
logic is thinking he's thinking about
okay gotta take
oh wow wow oh wow what a move by ludwig
great move very clean fantastic
very very clean
and uh i mean i don't know if logic is
going to trade here
probably okay he does trade you could
set a trap a3
set that trump i mean because he's got a
c it's a trap you got to start thinking
creatively normally you play
exactly so he plays that but now he
doesn't open his c
file so ludwig should just yeah okay
easy again don't make one move attacking
moves chat just because you can play
knight c2
doesn't mean you should then your knight
gets trapped
right exactly
clean clean clean clean doesn't even
have to castle king e7
okay he does castle that's fine
oh and to be clear just because i see
some chat is going insane there's no
bias here
um i just want to see good chess and i
feel like ludwig was really unfortunate
in the first team he got a great
position he was winning and it was real
heartbreak because he missed one move
um but there is no bias just to be clear
for everybody in chat who's going
insane i i totally want to see uh
playoffs every single time
um yeah i do too actually yeah i kind of
agree
you you do want to see that like dude
that first game yesterday between benji
fishy and
and negronu like that was crazy i mean
the whole comeback and like i mean it
was just it was great that those guys it
went down to the last 1.2 seconds
so right although benji tried to give
everybody a heart attack he should have
just won the game yes yes
30 seconds on the block it wasn't quite
a 1.2 he missed a mate you know but yeah
yeah
he's a fortnight the fortnite guy has
got to make it all dramatic exciting you
know down to the wire
right and um okay rook takes pawn
there's a little
problem the problem is black's knights
can't really get in the game easily
if logic takes upon d6 yeah please don't
go rook t8 oh my god please don't go
rook t8
that would be insane what a move
and now you can laterally swing it to d7
or e7
what a move yes rook d8 rushing with the
trade would have resulted in rook e8 you
lose a knight and then you're paralyzed
yeah that would have been that would
have been a serious throw
so rook a7 is a great move yeah
also rookie seven is kind of a rook lift
again remember in his match against
moist critical he missed a rook lift
so it's kind of like and rick actually
rick d7 is the best move
white can't sit white's gonna have to
trade his side straight off rooks here
and then white's left with one rook and
and ludwig should win this pretty
cleanly
yes very nice conversion from him
you know what's great is that every
match has been so close
yeah like how many matches of knock i
mean sardosh xqc was 2-0 but that very
easily could have been one
one yeah benji and daniel legrando went
to tire breaks niko and rubius went to
tie breaks this match is headed to tie
breaks
um moist rain wilson moist was
completely winning right that could have
very easily been
tie breaks too yeah very easily yeah
it sucks i mean it sucks those matches
that you you just have those winning
positions and your your nerves get the
best of you
uh it's it's gonna be
super i mean i know michelle is working
super hard i think her matches
is the day after tomorrow against mr
beast uh tomorrow is is is who it's
tubbo uh
tub over he has to be code miko code
yeah yeah called mikko
i said miko sorry i'm a surgery i
thought you said nico although it's kind
of the same
the same sound yes but that uh she by
the way she was grinding she did like
six hours of chess the other day man
she got tired of losing i mean she was
like it's uh
it's amazing amazing stuff um
yeah so i mean i think that's going to
be a really i that has potentially a
close match i do kind of think tubbo is
a big favorite
if i'm going to be honest uh i think
tubbo has like been been bossing it
uh he's been a little bit unlucky he was
a little bit unlucky i felt like some
some of the uh some of the matches were
some of the bracks were unfortunate
because i was thinking about nico
um with an n and i thought that uh if
she'd been in another bracket there's a
very good chance she could have made
champions and not been in the
consolation
but because she was in the bracket with
objectively i think the two strongest
players overall
is sardosh and benji she just like she
had no chance because they they both are
so strong
um but i think if she'd been in another
group she could have been champions
and i think in some ways the same goes
for tubbo too if he hadn't been in the
group with uh with logic and rayne
wilson i think there was a chance he
could have been in
champions as well well here's the thing
nobody knew benji fishy was going to
become a 1300 during the course of the
tournament right like that was insane
uh yeah like that kid
first of all has clearly some sort of
talent for the game because his growth
is insane
uh good coaching and hard work and
that's it
and um you know he signed by energy and
i said that they should re-up his
contract and give him a bonus he'll be a
chess creator for them as well
uh energy oh oh nrg okay yeah yeah okay
okay
so they should uh i mean the man's gonna
like enter some
i don't know chess creator events right
right yes
twitch rivals hand and brain you know
that kind of yeah yeah exactly
okay all right
okay so i think i think 94 is probably a
good move here for
for ludwig um let's see let's see what
happens
it's it's mayday i mean you get made it
very easily can you two night off
good game so i think um
yeah now probably knight f4 again no
real stylemate possibilities the only
thing white has is one a pawn to run
down the board not that it's going
anywhere but it's the one last trick you
have could play for stalemate with these
horses
but that would take
serious effort but hey xqc almost got
stalemated that first game if sardone
should push d4
toward the
by ludwig i guess you go a4 one last ho
prayer and a hope he goes rook a4 not a
bad try either trying to pick off one of
these ponies
um i said okay yeah many ways for
for ludwig to win here
if you go f3 there is obviously rook f3
although
you got to see that you got to see rook
f3 you got to not just move your knight
and hang your knight
never over yeah it's never or
i mean actually the it is true though if
you don't see f5
it is kind of tricky to play here like
king c2 now
you got to go kingston too then rook d2
checking you can use the other pony
to make the chucks but okay now knight
c3 and rook d1 it's an arabian checkmate
knight c3 and it's
the arabian mate here does does he i
mean
he also can go rook d1 and then knight
c3 so
yeah he but the thing is if he's not
confident after that first game
he's going to think he messed up and now
he's going to go panic mode and
play like knight takes f2 which is still
winning right
ludwig's been very composed here he
seems very composed and very measured
so i don't think he's just gonna panic
here uh now if he had like 30 seconds i
could see it but not with three minutes
on the clock
um i kind of think rook d1 is the move
he should be able to spot here
right because it's just like you know
what they're going to do
they're going to take and then knight c3
but so
he had almost dropped he almost played
knight g2 check and
i found it nice wow dude nice move by
ludwig
very nice move yeah that's it it's mate
yep sick suck me
very nice game bye very nice
strictly better strictly better there's
nothing
else to say
well how about this i mean we honestly
don't know what the heck is going on
there we just had two games where there
was bishop odds by move five six
right like like we we need an equal game
hikara that's what we need
yeah and i think we're going to get a
more even game in the in the blitz game
because i suspect that ludwig starts
with white so
uh probably logic has spoken to his
coach or his coaches or
and he'll have some idea how to improve
and not blunder a piece in the opening
but
it definitely feels like whether it's
just the nerves of the bracket stage
it feels like logic is certainly he
hasn't quite been himself today it feels
like just
the way that he's been blundering a
five-minute game
ludwig with the white pieces because
he's the hire of the two seeds
five minute no increment winner takes
all we'll be right back
uh all right boys game three the only
thing um
i can say is logic has some really good
attacks
that if you're a great player and know
how to ford off
empty threats then easy clap but
like he always has an attack that whole
game too he's down like what like two
[ __ ] pieces
and i still feel like my dick's against
the wall
[Music]
so in a 5-0
i don't know if he can come up with
those ideas but i certainly will have to
avoid them
i gotta piss
[Music]
[Music]
yo
so right off the rip i mean both these
games have been exciting but
um the fact of the matter is i am way
well better versed
more well-versed in the openings and
he's still definitely in the game even
after i've been up a piece in both games
within like
you know seven ten moves whatever it is
so i am thinking about that
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
pogchamps 3 presented by grip 6.
we just saw a one-to-one head-to-head
between
ludwig and logic weird game cecaro and
now they have to play a tiebreaker
ludwig's got white five minutes what are
we expecting
yeah so i think um in terms of in terms
of the
five minute game i would say that i
think that ludwig was probably the
favorite again based on the amount of
games he's played combined with the fact
that i think
logic has focused primarily on playing
rapid games he seems to be very
methodical in his approach and the way
that he thinks on every single move
um for the most part so i think that
there should be a slight edge for ludwig
that being said logic is
boasting you're not posting sorry
beasting with a 1202 rating in blitz
chess
i don't know yeah if logic has played a
lot of blitz or what's going on
um go ahead no i was going to say we got
a scotch and i was just
okay uh did did logic prepare something
because surely
yeah he did he improves i i was sure he
had an improvement
i don't like this line improvement line
though necessarily i still would have
played bishop b6
yes the guards i don't i thought the
idea of bishop b6 and knight f6
even if it's not correct at the grand
master level it's a simple free-flowing
plan
playing queen x6 is much more
double-edged that being said
look at ludwig he's deep in the tank if
white doesn't know what to do it can be
very dangerous for white as well
but when you study this line you got to
remember what to do against queen f6
it's the only move
i mean there's bishop b6 but there's
also you know uh and we're obviously not
going to have any
any throbbing checkmates but he i think
he's good at castles now we need we need
logic not to take on d4 too quickly to
give ludwig again very tough position
for both players um
i mean personally i i think if if logic
plays queen g6 here it gets very spicy
immediately
um the idea of playing knight g7 which
is well known theory
at the top grand master level it's a
good move i think it's a lot harder to
play
so logic is just going to castle's king
to the queen side which actually you
know i kind of like here even if it's
not
objectively the best way to play it's a
very simple plan yeah
so he i think he's gonna he's named snap
castle the problem is
between the two players one guy's got a
stack of pieces in front of his king and
right
ludwig might just snap off b4 without
even thinking
and that would make the game insane but
logic has got to move here
yeah he's gotta go you just gotta go
yeah
one thing i would say as well as when he
played the armageddon game against rayne
wilson when he got really low on time he
just panicked and started going kamikaze
mode he just hung a bishop and then a
rook
um and so i think it's imperative for
logic that he doesn't
get way behind on the clock at any
moment here not more than probably a
minute yeah
i'm literally just gonna say if you're
playing a five minute game for anybody
that wants to kind of set yourself these
uh these kind of time frames it's like
40 seconds one minute and don't watch my
speed just championship matches but
um for yourselves you should try to keep
like a comfortable barrier in a 15
minute game
car would you say like four or five
minute barrier like at most
two three minute i think it all depends
on the level i think
i mean i think the grand master level if
you understand the concepts or it's like
one move if one if you play one move and
there's a tactical sequence that wins
the game you can essentially use as much
time as you need to like five or six
minutes five to ten minutes even
but i would say at this level probably
not more than two to three minutes on a
single
also i would say as well um there is
another there is another remedy
to problems levy which is that if you're
if you really are worried about your
time usage you can uh download a google
chrome extension with
levies voice and my voice as well which
will tell you to move you can set it to
like five seconds 30 seconds
um or minutes or percentage of time so
there's a google chrome
uh download which the players might want
to uh use if they have the opportunity
or an extension sir i did not think that
was where you were going with that i
thought you were going to say check into
therapy but
yeah that's uh that that extension might
honestly give you there uh
might make you have to check into
therapy yeah shout out to jack lee that
guy's that guy's always coming up with
new and creative ideas he uh
he found a way to beat a bot only by
pre-moving on chess.com and it forced
them to like recode the way the bot
plays but i love queen a4 by largely
even if it's not the best move i love it
it's aggressive
oh no no no no although
i'm not taking him with the pawn there
oh he might play king b8 dude he might
play king b8 just
oh my gosh queen tunneling he's just
tunneling the whole queen side oh man oh
now he's got a really just okay b6 queen
eight is made
and oh c6 it should be six
that's actually i don't hate that move
man i don't hate that move and if black
can get the knife to f4
he has all kinds of threats with
checkmates yeah that rook is guarded and
it's getting closer on time it's about
10 seconds now
okay we went a lot uh willing to ludwig
[Music]
he just takes
oh my gosh sure d2 work takes knight he
hung his knight takes night
[Music]
oh no rook takes knight oh no oh my gosh
that's insane wait let's
let's just bring that back um
oh rook takes knight and now queen f2
queen g2 is just game over
like yeah and oh and he's queen of two
oh no
oh no oh no
queen f2 logic misses it queen of two
oh no the only one oh we missed it
and now he's right because me ludwig has
a force made in two
and now he's mated what a throw
king eight and then queen c8 and there's
actually a staircase checkmate oh
man logic through 87's mate mate
rookie sixth grade seven's queen d7
there's three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw
let's go
[Music]
i was scared for a moment there was some
f2 action
oh he sees it yeah it doesn't matter his
chat's gonna definitely tell him now for
sure
no he said he said he was scared there
was f2 action so he
he must have seen it that is completely
insane rook d2
queen f2 that was that was entertaining
but i feel like i just lost some time
off my life i mean that was uh that was
just so stressful as a spectator if you
were a fan of of either of those two and
now the worst part is it's not even the
group stage someone is going home
and um so
we will bring in the players for
interviews don't go anywhere
park champs three percent of my grip six
returns in a moment
ah
got rid of you early just wanted to say
hope you have a nice stream oh yeah
thank you bobby i remember reading that
i remember reading that [ __ ] thank you
dude for reading your host earlier
appreciate it man white to move
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
black to move
no oh cause white's there
do i sacrifice my queen ah i do okay
take there
this takes
oh this is a tricky one
maybe it's not that tricky actually if i
go here
it's out of here
do
[Music]
uh-huh
free
what is what trying to do here
oh i don't know that's black all right i
what
chuck here that's just taken though
[Music]
take here and that goes there and then i
go
here
this guy ah yes
uh
you can check
take here
welcome back everyone we're joined now
by the players and uh
you know i always start with with the
winner but i honestly
ludwig just before you got here i was
talking to logic briefly and i was like
that was you know i was like that was
that was rough like how you know and
he's kind of telling me
i just want you to tell me to tell tell
everybody what you told me man because
your mentality through all this you know
people people in a game like that would
be stressed angry
your mentality is very different so i
mean i'm going home to a fine ass woman
and
a baby so i'm happy i mean and at the
end of the day this is for charity
this is my first time and i i wouldn't
want to easy win like
it was very you know he played really
great and yeah there's nerves that come
with it when you have
thousands and thousands of people
watching you it's not like
performing that's easy that's what i do
like i say like i'm a rapper i'm not a
chess player professionally
even though i love the game so there's
things that i miss there's things that
i still don't see and i don't
necessarily see it as a negative
you know because people could be [ __ ]
boys about it and try to be like oh you
lost or you this or you that's like no i
won
i made money for a charity and i'm happy
but i did take a l to my man's
bloodwork today so i will wholeheartedly
admit that
um but you know missing things like like
in this in this last game with the with
the mate in two
um it just gets me more excited to
further learn the language of chess and
have the vision for it so at the end of
the day it's like we had fun
um you know it's all going to charity
and hopefully you guys will let me come
back because i'm about to be i'm going
to be on it now
ludwig congrats man now you got
you got to top that off man how do you
feel how'd you bounce back
is two matches now where you you you
start with the with the oh one what do
you do to
what do you do to get hyped up motivated
to
to win it after taking a loss in the
first game i think logic
is is uh i mean a hell of a public
speaker but everything he says
is uh is resoundingly true that like
i got checkmated on on a1
and i will that will never happen to me
again and so the biggest takeaway
is uh i've improved my game of chess so
that's i can uh
i can i can take that away but i felt
good after i got a dm from hess
my best friend magnus we were chatting a
bit about like you know thank you
uh yeah where finland is on the map um
but i felt fine because um because i was
winning in the opening and i i think
that was
where i cause i don't know dude logic is
crazy man it's like no matter what i did
he always had an attack
and it was terrifying that i was up six
in game two
and uh yeah second game i really did
mess up with that bishop and i should
have just brought it back for sure
but i don't know why it's like saw that
square i was like i'll be fine here
and your night ticket is hilarious yeah
it was an early lead and that made it
feel better but um
i mean hats off to you because it did
not feel good um
one getting stomps game one and then
game three was
terrible i felt terrible the whole time
i started just nod in my stomach
well hey caro we were we didn't know who
to pick right beforehand
i mean this was such a tense match i
mean i think hikaro would you say that
logic played like the best game start to
finish in all the pog champs like that
first game against rain that's why we
just didn't know
like yeah i was kind of curious actually
in terms of logic it must have felt much
different than when you were playing
in the group stage because your accuracy
and just the general general moves that
you found
they were a little bit different it felt
like that you made some mistakes today
and did you feel there was a difference
between when you were playing just
prior to the bracket stage just playing
individual and trying to figure out
which group you would end up in or was
it all
kind of the same and it's just like
things just went a little bit
differently today
it was kind of the same i just think i i
knew that
um ludwig is a really good player like i
feel like we
i feel like take all the pressure away
and it would be like fun to just like
play against them i think it would be
like really good matches in general um
but having never been involved
in a tournament or anything it was like
yeah like nerves but not even like
oh i'm scared it wasn't like that it was
just like oh [ __ ] i got to think about
all these things that i usually don't
think about like time really matters and
if i do this and if i do that and then
you just kind of start overthinking it
but that's how i was when i would rap
you know it's like i'd be on stage and
you forget a word and you beat yourself
up about it and you practice and you
practice and you practice and you
practice
so that those mistakes don't happen and
those jitters don't necessarily happen
anymore
i'm excited for that to continue with
chess
and even outside of pog champs in itself
like i want to play as many tournaments
as i can like this
fun and it wouldn't be as fun if it
wasn't as challenging because
of you know having a fantastic opponent
who's
a really good player i think that's a
very
very good mentality well we got we got
ludwig you're you're going into
the semi-final yeah um you know
there's been a lot made of the different
players involved in the semi-final
there's
it's a lot of players you yourself i
heard you on a stream one say you
thought you might be the worst player in
the champions bracket i don't want you
to think that way we got logic here
he's hyping it all up you're in a
semi-final with rayne wilson
and benji fishy saying it out loud
doesn't change the fact i yes
exactly what you said i am in a
semi-final with benji fishy
a 16-year-old cracked genius sardoche
like a 1500 man
and then reign wilson i am not sitting
pretty in this tournament but
uh look at the end of the day uh i think
i've been more nervous for this pog
champs than any other pog champs
i don't know why even my poops have been
weird today and i think it's because
i've been nervous
i uh we didn't all right well i'm just
letting you know
that this is what pogchamps is doing to
me it's sucking my soul away levy
okay all i can do is go out there and
play the best chess i can and
if that's enough hell yeah and if it's
not then shame but
that's all i got all right
well on the note of ludwig's fecal
matter we're going to thank you both
for the epic games today uh logic i'm
sure
chess.com will have you back for
anything chess related in the future
music related uh maybe you guys can do
uh some sort of music thing as well i
know
ludwig did like a christmas track so
that'd be pretty dope dude don't tell
logic about my christmas album
yeah we should just start a rap group it
was good i'm down i'm down we gotta i do
a holiday i'm a holiday guy only
you know love him come on it was so good
give yourself some credit yeah all right
ludwig best of luck in the semi-final
logic it was amazing calling your games
thank you both
and uh we'll see ludwig we'll see you in
the semis peace out good games man
bye guys all right ikaru we've got
we've got our champions bracket
semi-final how's that looking man
yeah i think it's going to be exciting i
think um you know i think the thing is
you see little cracks like little chinks
and the
chinks in the armor as we say um where
was sargo
i think we all thought he's just amazing
like just grinding shots 10 hours plus
every single day
and um he basically keeps uh he was
playing really well and then when he
played uh
benji benji kind of cut through cut
through sort of
the armor do you want to call it he just
cut through and uh and he beat sargeras
and xqc got a winning position against
sardos as well
so um we're we're starting to see you
know that anything can happen
yeah absolutely uh i think ludwig should
be full of confidence i mean he's also
going doing good training
working on his openings and you said it
best i mean i've got nothing else to add
we've seen chips in everybody's armor so
this is exciting we've got one more
matchup coming up today between pokemon
and
uh myth but first we're gonna take a
short break and tell you
about our official sustainability
partner for this event chat you already
know what to do you've been here for
you've been here for a while give a
shout out to guayaqui and their 25 years
of regenerative
yerba mate spam that emote in the chat
for a chance to win
and uh we'll be right back four pillars
of regeneration to heal
all nations we work with and not against
because we are a part of this we've
never been apart from this
our hands feel through the soils past
our
feet touch on the blades of grass raid
all these voices into a beautiful
tapestry find those similarities we all
share in these breaths that we breathe
this home of ours sustains us but needs
us
so together we'll move through this long
night and inspire
us all to come to life
[Music]
encounter
when i close my eyes i can almost
um
[Music]
you make me
ah
[Music]
i'm playing blitzy oh we could go off
emote only since it hasn't started yet
[Music]
oh whoops oh dude i need a okay dude
[Music]
all right here we go
[Music]
your breath again fill up my
[Music]
i'll
lungs
[Music]
i remember you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
hey
all right moving this up is bad
[Music]
oh
there's a distance between eyes
like slower left out the name of the
game baby
speed chess or speed
[Music]
ah
actual accidents
[Music]
can't afford it oh no
[Applause]
[Music]
again
quack quack
hey me again luscious larry leather
browns
sweaty heavy pocky leather wow
no wait don't kiss him i'm your son i'm
here from the future
if you kiss him i won't exist so please
hey i love your belt is that what you
wear in the future
oh rad totally what my grip 6 belt
i know right i love this no flailing
flaps
bulging buckles or hideous holes and
with a lifetime guarantee you really
can't go
mother whoa
welcome back everyone to our coverage of
puckchamps 3 presented by
the amazing american-made grip six
they've sold out
of all of their chest themed wallets but
they're because they're super popular
obviously uh in fact i got one uh but
uh before pogchamps is over you can
check out their belts their wallets
their socks i'm wearing some right now
hicaro are you
yes you are no i'm not right now but i
do have them sitting on my
uh chair right well
we don't we don't need to do a live demo
i do have them on they are the short
ankle red ones very comfortable
not going to tell you how long i've worn
them though because that would be
terrifying
uh but you can check out go.chest.com
grip6 use the code pochamps 20 get 20
off but let's also tell you about other
percents off and percents and what's
going to charity
we all know about the community outreach
initiative which is actually hikaru why
so many of these players even played
because they thought it was great they
thought they would play some chess learn
some chess
and give away some of their winnings to
uh to charity and every single
person whatever place they get that
percentage equal amount will be donated
to the charity of their choosing so
yeah correct that's a little feel-good
moment there as we've got one
match remaining your thoughts on
pokemane versus
myth so i think this is probably the
match where there's uh
out of all the matches i've seen in the
constellation and the championship
bracket where i think objectively
there's probably the biggest mismatch
um but again we we play the game because
uh
if we didn't then we would have already
just handed the crown to sardosh i think
before the event started and
yes while sardosh is looking very good
in the champions bracket he did lose to
benji fishy
and um and of course he still will have
to beat ludwig and or beat benji to to
win the championship bracket so that's
why we play the game
but if i'm being truly objective i do
think pokemon she's been putting a lot
of work she came very close to
taking a game off of xqc in the group
stage um she beat rubius
so i think the pokemon is the clear
favorite in this match
yes uh her kind of growth her
games against uh xqc even very like very
close that second game
up a piece has to fill in the gaps uh so
she's actually not streaming she's going
full focus
a myth was putting in some work with uh
with maurice ashley his openings look
great
uh so i do think that pokey is if i have
to give the not to someone it's it's uh
it's pokey but we're about to see myth
is finishing up a game
uh and just also want to give some love
to
a few folks uh the shanpai uh
d'amsa someone named anonymous someone
anonymously donated
uh super caught and uh daylighter and
zombie lawyer they all donated
daylighter in particular donated a
hundred dollars
you guys can use that button below the
video player uh and i'm gonna read this
out
because he shouted me i feel like i
don't want to do no wall him even though
it's not my stream crossed a thousand
rapid today just in time for my birthday
so thank you to daylighter also said
gotta thank levy for the danish and the
dutch videos
you're welcome uh but uh thank you for
the 100
donation that's huge oh we got moves
they just started them asap
my god they just they didn't even wait
myth was done they just
got him in and and here we go so we have
a game
we have the london system yes and knight
c6 another guy
who's going for this knight c6 they got
to start moving that seat on that's what
they got yeah so i
i think again myth is playing playing
for the opening setup that i recommended
to um
uh xqc yesterday i think it's pretty
reasonable
um but we're but already myth is
thinking so he's kind of channeling his
inner xqc and thinking here very early
in the game
um but he has to have been ready for the
london system because pokeman has played
this i believe every single game so far
yes the thing about the london is that
you can prepare for it you still need a
line i mean i
listen i once had to play eric rosen in
a match where he only played the london
i didn't help my cause it was annoying
um
i also just want to quickly give a shout
out to actually to chester to our very
own chess play with the 250 dollar
contribution chat so uh do we these
things kind of go one after the other
i think that you know once a few people
are are giving to charity
that uh we'll have a we'll have kind of
a
snowball effect but she goes for this
bishop b5 again i love this it worked
against rubius
this night yeah i think it's a great
opening choice okay so a6 so she takes
probably you just play knight d2 and c4
here in 95. oh she's going very good
move he's just going for it uh i hope
myth doesn't play queen d7 and i
to be honest also hope he doesn't play
queen d6 so
queen d6 is a very tricky move but yeah
i i think we'll see what happens here
and um i made my bet so i i made my bet
the odds were too good so i
i had to i had to bet accordingly even
though i think i'll probably lose my
points uh
it was good value that's okay do you
think it was good value that gamestop
went up to 200 today
it's 181 in the in the after hours
market but
anyway that's a topic for a whole
another day yes uh trading was halted
you know when it almost quadrupled that
was good that was good it was a nice
little ending to the day
yeah that that now unfortunately what
that means is that probably for the next
like
two days at least until the weekend all
streams are going to be inundated with
non-stop
diamond hands total and all this other
all this other nonsense
yes yes yes but ethereum looking good as
well
you know uh but we're going to talk we
can talk crypto uh at a different moment
myth has gone like
this i'll reiterate what what charlie
munger said today here at the conference
in la which is that
it's sort of the uneatable combined with
the unspeakable
that's all i'm gonna say okay
what does that mean i don't know i'm not
charlie monger oh okay fair anyway all
right
i don't know i was like i was like am i
dumb like do i not i don't all right
all right i yeah charlie monger there we
go that's
anyway all right um pretty good start
for for
for pokemon she should probably take the
pawn or play f3
both moves are very good here i i mean
yeah i think knight c6 because she's
going to be like am i missing something
so we're probably going to get knight c6
queen
please don't go queen d6 so just queen
d7 i don't want anyone move blunders i'm
done with one move blunders
um hey queen d7 95 queen b5
like yeah i mean i think it's very
unclear what's what's happening it's i
think white is up a pawn but there's a
lot of a lot of tricky opportunities
here for both sides
a lot of possibilities
mitch just has two queen moves so one is
slightly more active than the other he's
got four queen moves to hang a queen
so he's got two queen moves and right
so i think i mean he can go he can
either play queen to d7 or queen to c8 i
think 27 is more
more likely just because it's natural
move uh
bringing the queen more into the game
okay knight drops back an hour
will he follow the path follow the
yellow brick road out to b5
very scary move at the same time i kind
of think it's likely that he will
because he wants to go forward i think
when you're new to the game
pushing your pieces forward it makes a
lot of sense yeah see queen a4 is the
other move here
that i think is very possible but i
think one of these two moves will be
played i just don't know which one
especially because some of the players
have click on
like they oh my god he almost played f6
he almost played f6 and now he
um yeah how he plays queen b5
good move yeah very good move by meth
beautiful he hits b2
and that stops white from castling now
pokey seems like a sis like a system
player she really likes to get
kind of a nice comfortable position that
she that she can
mess around in and make things happen
but she's already dealing with some very
serious threats
and myth is dealing with a red bar
connection what's going on with myth
oh it's back back yeah
all right she's
let's see what she does here i mean b3
is the best move i could see her playing
queen c1 also
yes when the queen comes out you've just
got to look straight down
what's under attack b2 uh definitely
pawn push is the first thing you think
of
and as you said queen c1
but she might go knight c3 but
that's a lot of options here a lot of
options um for pokemon in this position
i think
i think if she can get out of this
opening stage the next couple of moves
without making a blunder i think it's
very likely she'll win the game because
i think for myth it's very hard to
develop here
um it's very hard also with the queen in
the night a lot of pieces out in the
center they can be attacked very easily
i think the next like probably three to
five moves will be very critical
in terms of uh who's gonna win this game
yeah honestly just a tense moment i mean
we've said everything there is to say
about this position
chad how are you all doing you guys are
uh energetic it's been one of those
the longest broadcast of pogchamps we
ever had double header we had to switch
commentators it was uh
you know it's been an intense day uh i
was here so i
anna doing her first uh commentary saw
anna cranling that is
she does play knight c3 by the way so
queen b2 is she gonna take on d5 is that
what she saw
i'm not sure what she's gonna do here i
um
yeah i'm really not sure i think
anything could happen
but i think 94 is much more likely
objectively
just take on e4 and then castle
something like that
it almost reminds you of the rubius game
when like his queen got in here and then
he like
left it and then he brought in too many
pieces he didn't develop everything so
myth needs to
press the button stop it and then but
yeah very very tense moment though very
very tense for both sides
do we know if if if poki's been
practicing
with like her pokeman account and then
another one because she seems
she seems above this 700 elo um
yes i i will say that i think like most
other players in the
event i do believe pokemon has a second
account as well which she has been
playing on i haven't looked recently but
um but i do believe she has a second
account
okay in fact i think most players do
like i do believe also as an example i
believe that rayne wilson who has played
a whopping total of something like 20
games
um on the account wearing wilson i'm
pretty sure
pretty sure that he has another unnamed
uh
count on chess.com yeah it just seems
kind of crazy that a guy you know only
played magnus like three years ago and
then
is uh yeah he's definitely up there in
terms of skill
uh uh we got queen b2 by the way so
pokey plays knight b5 man
this is gonna get removed from pokemon
really really good
this could get really bad really quickly
because myth doesn't have a check
they're both covered is he gonna play
knight c3
oh my god i mean i don't know what he's
gonna do here but
yeah we'll see very very soon we'll see
he might play rook c8 i mean he might
just see knight c7 and just play rook to
c8
that also could happen
i really want to know on uh he's
clicking around he sees
he saw e6 which by the way might be like
some sort of brilliant sacrifice
crazy attack maybe yeah i mean
and if you really can't spot here
if i protect and attack
oh don't go back to b5 knight cc oh that
would be
no no don't go to b5 don't go back
could go to b7 true true
oh good move by myth good move
the problem here however is that i think
in this position
um what's gonna happen is once pokemon
castles are king
yeah myth is in very bad shape because
it's very hard to develop that being
said e6 here would
would actually trap the white knight and
then it's gonna be very hard for pokemon
to respond here
well does she have to play like rugby
one or knight c4 sometimes uh i think
probably c4 and go for queen a4
although queen b5 unfortunately now
allows c4 immediately because the knight
protects c4
if pokeman finds c4 i think she's well
on her way to a victory yeah otherwise
queen b5 is a fantastic move like
finding c4 that's the difference at this
level it's the gluing of the position
seeing although to be fair levy there's
a very dirty idea knight takes c7 rook
c7 rook b1
i think with an idea of rook be a chuck
mate
maybe it's not maybe it's not a force
checkmate but it looks very dangerous as
well
yeah that king on e8 really looking a
little bit suspicious
she needs to also not do the thing where
you get like tunnel vision like knight
c7 she doesn't
need to go like knight f7 or knight g6
or any of that insane stuff
uh but right now when you see this you
think
they want my knight you look at check
exactly yep
no checks no captures you gotta find
this move
and you gotta realize it's guarded
and yeah we don't we don't have we don't
have pokey screen so we don't know what
arrows she's drawing so
can't move you gotta find c4 maybe she
goes f3
another option it's possible i still
think c4 is very
very likely here um but not sure
oh goes f3 good move though it's a good
move because again
for mitt the problem is he has no
development so even if even if
objectively there are easier ways for
white to win
the fact that myth does not have any
development the king the bishop and the
brook are all in their original squares
work on c8 it's not on its original
square but it's not an active piece
either i'm very
very afraid from it and now myth has to
not make the mistake of being like oh
she wants my knight i can't let her have
it like don't just take on d5 dude
you know um white's advantage rests in
the fact that white is castle like if
black gets e6 bishop out castle black is
fine
so exactly
stressful like myth needs to not go i
gotta move my knight and then
start getting even more delaying in his
development
yeah exactly so i mean i don't know i
don't know
this has been a very slow paced game
compared to that those last two and he
just takes on d5
nice
nice queen takes
okay so of course she can take she also
does have c4 again
i think she'll just take the knight of
course and if
if pokeyman can see pawn to c4 again
this is what the whole game hinges on
will she find pawn to c4
that being said queen takes pawn on e4
was a really really nice move by myth
here
yes um but but the problem i think for
actually for myth is that for pokemon
she should see that the pawn is under
attack from the queen and the bishop on
the diagonal
so she pushes his pawn forward i think
she again
if she pushes the c pawn and sees the
idea of the queen check on a4
um i think that she's gonna win the game
but she has to see that idea
yeah she might play c3 which is very
london style
but uh yes good point that's also very
good
just push that c pawn and see the see
the wing check although queen two is
very nice as well very dangerous
yeah queen takes a6 i like that just as
much as c3 or c
to be honest i didn't know what she was
going to play if not for moving the c
pawn i didn't even think that like she
would just sneak out get the pawn taken
uh and then and now now by the way e6
queen a6 the rook is hanging oh man this
could go downhill quickly
correct yeah yeah it could definitely go
downhill in a hurry for myth here um
uh if if uh if he doesn't find a way to
develop his king here
22 is a very very good move
just you got no checks you got no
captures attached to
weak pieces
yeah so i mean i think for myth it's
very hard to play here very very hard to
play here
um f6 again yeah but see the problem
with f6 here is i think we've told
a lot of the streamers especially the
ones who are very new to the game the
idea of pushing a pawn like the f pawn
is very shaky and now pokemon should see
queen takes pawn here on a6
yeah because the queen is on the
diagonal it's eyeing the pawn so i think
she will say that she can take
yeah the dangerous thing is that now of
course smith wants to move his bishop
and i see him kind of like
you know he's ready to go but he pushed
that pawn now his rook is not guarded
and she takes it uh oh
um okay yeah she could go here
no my my king takes it actually never
mind i'm trolling
um but the rook don't forget about the
rook my rook
is under threat good because of that
move she just made
nice
about to move the rook over
now if pokemate says queen a4 she's
going to win
is a nice move as well to trade off some
rooks and go down to the end of the
board
yes this is actually an insane position
because white is only up a pawn
but it's plus nine because of how
weak the king is uh rook b1 like icarus
said or look for the check
don't go queen c6 do not trade queens
do not and even then maybe you're still
going to win but don't trade queens so
queen
yeah i think rook b1 and queen a4 both
moves are very cleanly winning here
um i think rook b1 is actually a very
natural move to play here
i think it's a very natural move to to
try and create checkmates also i know
pokemon likes
likes the background checkmate theme so
i can see rook b1 and she could see like
oh no no oh that's a huge mistake
i mean i think she's still going to win
the game but that is a huge mistake by
pokeman but
myth is clicking his king like he's
clicking his king he he doesn't even see
back backward queen right now
oh wait no no he just saw it he just
clicked this queen these guys are
terrifying me with their clicking
you just look at his screen right now
it's it's a
no but he sees the bishop guards the
queen is he gonna trade
oh he played oh oh oh oh no oh
oh no no no no
oh no oh
he saw that he was guarded but he didn't
and look at pokeman
oh my gosh
she is taking her time i don't think
she's gonna miss it
one thing that pokeman has been really
good at is checkmating pattern she's
done a lot of puzzles and i do think
she's gonna see it
the only reason she might not see it is
she might see the fork with knight takes
pawn and just trade the queen
yes she might play queen to and no no no
no
just know
that was clean and now she's going to
feel bad because she spent so much time
she's going to be like oh my god i had
me no you're just not sure though you're
like it looks like it
it looks like it and you await the
little sign
you await the little sound from.com that
goes
because sometimes you do it exactly yeah
and the sound doesn't go off and you're
like
uh oh oh my bad
my not bad i uh
i play with sounds off like a madman
that's why sometimes i
don't know when they move and i lose on
time when i'm talking to my chat but
impressive game no from pokey that was
good very impressive i mean queen c6 was
not
i think i mean it would have been better
with queen a4 queen d7 but nonetheless a
very impressive start from here here in
this first match of the uh
of the the bracket stage also big shout
out to ludwig who who um
who i feel like in the first podcast was
saying i hate chess it's such a hard
game and now i see ludwig tweeting 10
minutes ago saying i love chess
so um yes did you hear that ludwig was
such a fan of the game
yes i remember when i when when we were
younger it was uh it was very cool to
like write a facebook status like ah
chess is so i hate chess or you know
chess is the best then it would always
get a lot of
you know a lot of attraction no it's
it's yeah you're the best and then it's
like you nerd go back go go back and
yes don't remind me of middle school man
i was just forgetting about it and now
all right well on that note congrats to
pokey on the first win
uh myth has to strike back now with the
white pieces might be our last game of
the day might have a blitz playoff we'll
be right back
i really like her have that [ __ ]
that hurts that hurted
[Music]
are you on mod to bet no
gg that was uh
yeah i really i really oofs their
damage
wait why did i castle here instead
why did i move my rook forward i could
have just done
i just wasn't paying it oh man that's
embarrassing as well i actually had a
great opportunity to castle
i threw down
all right we go next game
only big problem is that you're way too
passive gg though well i mean i don't
think that's a problem
well not that it's a problem but it's
like i felt like
i was trying to find things to like make
me positive i wasn't trying to just go
even
but i guess sometimes it's not bad to go
even and i think that's my mistake which
is
being too passive at the end of the day
you guys are right actually i guess i
don't think about it as passiveness i
just think like i'm trying to go for
other things
instead of going for like simple trades
that could potentially do more for me in
the long run and put me in a better
position
you cannot castle right side
yeah let's analyze real quick
holy [ __ ] that was
yeah that would have been a good trade
i have to go castle this way whoops my
bad
like i should have went for this too
dude
and i needed to move
oh my god i knew i should have taken it
dude [ __ ]
i lose here as well no the best okay the
best is literally just take
and he takes and then
welcome back everyone to punch champs
three presented by grip6
it's been a long day it's been a long
day and uh for our final match
pokey struck first in a spot where it
was clean
it was just a small slip up worth the
queen trade but
she finds the mate and uh you know i saw
myth analyzing his game afterward
i hope he doesn't get too frustrated
because you know hikaru like we talk
about people in their seating
it was really rough for him he was in
maybe the worst group of all the players
maybe michelle had it bad too
which group was he in again he had nico
he had nico
benji and sardosh like oh
oh he was in he was in the group of
death yeah yeah that's actually
really harsh um yikes that that that's
actually brutal
yes yeah i was gonna say it's like you
know for nico for example i as i said if
she had been another group i think she
had a shot but she was in the group with
with a benjamin sardosh and i felt like
nico was was really strong so yeah myth
got really unlucky in the groups
um they played three players who all
could have easily been in the
championship bracket so he was in the he
was in the group of death
i mean the group of death uh actually
sorry to cut you off
or to interject again but isn't that the
um isn't that football
world cup some sort of like isn't that a
league of legends term too something
related to tsm
oh maybe but i know that like you you
can be in a group of death and like
knockouts be in in football in like the
world cup right
it's world cup yeah yeah uh you have
some crazy teams and like three great
teams and only two will make it or
whatever i don't even
man i uh yeah i know i mean i feel bad
for this certainly it's been
really really rough um because it's true
i think if you look at the other groups
for example the group with michelle
karen mr beast there were
groups like that or no sorry mr beast
and code miko
there could he maybe he could have ended
up in a slightly softer group so he got
really unlucky um ending up in the group
of death
but again he has a chance here he's he's
played well and he could have been in
that first game against pokemon
yes well no he he for him and michelle
uh
michelle before pogchamps knew zero like
literally zero and i remember
uh we had an introductory just like
phone call conversation she was like
what would be the final step of my
challenge accepted like would i play the
beth harmon bots like what would i do
um i think our contract ended with them
so we don't even have them anymore so i
can't even talk about them scratch that
but uh you know and i said pog champs
but it's going to be tough
but hicaro i never thought it would be
that tough the lowest rated player in
her group was like 900
i mean yeah i think it's been it's been
amazing the grind
uh and this is something that i actually
i spoke a little bit with ludwig about
uh
everyone everyone i think thinks there's
some magic beef that i have with a lot
of
obviously i don't um but i was talking
to ludwig and it's true that kind of
in the in this event it seems like some
of the players they really put their
heads down and they've been grinding
very hard and that doesn't just apply to
like
the star doshes of the world or um or
the xqc's of the world
but like even some of these newcomers
like pokeman for example or michelle
care they've really been putting in
a lot of time and effort so um it's kind
of the natural sort of effect i think
you see some streamers
have more time others have commitments
it's all it's all in the streamers in
terms of how much time they they put in
yeah
and the communities right because i feel
like pokey like she
it was positive and she had good
coaching and everything and i feel like
it can be tough like i think myth even
has struggled with it i mean when he
plays he gets
he gets like caught up but sometimes i
see some of the crazy stuff in there
like you know why are you doing this go
back to you know first person shooter
i'm like
oh it's it's brutal we're like well i
mean as as uh
as i think pokemon put it so eloquently
in her tweet she said
i'll i won't say the word on stream but
she said basically if people are gonna
say something about me it might as well
you know eff it and do whatever i want
to do so
i think some communities have been much
more supportive than others and uh it's
like yeah it's it's
it's difficult i've seen some of the
stuff in this chat um but again you know
we are all streamers at the end of the
day and
um i think we all have to deal with that
on some level or another
oh yeah uh absolutely i mean when you
play auto chess
how good are you at autos just now i
know they don't pay us for oh i love
auto chess oh there you go but my
community they
they they know that i'm going to be a
paper at anything except shots so they
they've like they've accepted that um so
they've been pretty mild towards
yeah the the the other day i hit my peak
sr in overwatch and i think that if i
ever get to diamond i might stream it
again but
not with voice comes on because the last
time i did that i almost got to s
so ah well but i mean if you do that
then half your chat is going to be like
oh you're so bad at this like go back to
us
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean and i don't
mean i mean like they're literally going
to say that
right um and i think at some point it
gets hard because you just want to enjoy
yourself and have a good time
now pokemon finds knight takes d4 here
i'm gonna be ridiculously impressed
yeah knight d4 is crazy having said that
hikaro if she scans for captures it's
the only capture she has
and then she has to find knight f3 true
true so that's where the thought process
comes in knight d4 bishop d7 and then
whoops suicide factory yeah
does xqc come up with a name for
in-between move
i don't think so you you mean the
in-between and then that you take and
then you take yeah
yeah i don't know i don't think so but i
think you're gonna now he's probably
gonna watch his broadcast
he's gonna come up with something really
random out of the blue for that i'm sure
actually levy i got the idea you know
you know what we need to do we need to
uh publish a book
once xcc comes with a few more terms we
just need to publish our book
um with all the new chess terms and we
just sell it and if every person on
twitch buys it for like one buck we'll
be
we'll both be worth like uh 100 million
dollars
oh well oh that'll i mean that'll double
your net worth that will that will
definitely uh
you know i had this idea but i think you
were playing in a tournament so i
couldn't even share it with you
um it was gonna be like you know chess
for five heads i made like a video
way back in the day before queen's
gambit before and it was uh before
juicer before any of that stuff
so yeah yeah it'll be a nice big
coloring book and
a picture book not coloring i'm not
going to color it um
chad you'll buy it right i guess i'll
buy it
well yeah of course we will buy it once
once they've made all their money on amc
and gme
um yeah they will we'll do like a hikaru
chest never has the drops they don't
have the drops you know like in video
games so do drops on your free book
and then there you go amazon listen up
all right we got a business proposal um
mitt's got to win this game though so
he's got to not trade too many pieces
okay i like c4 i don't think it's a bad
move but dc4 knight c4
b5 and then he has to find and you know
the one good thing i would say for myth
here is that i think he has some
experience in this because he
i believe in the in the first match he
played against benji fishy i think benji
also played a french
and i think it was an exchange french if
i'm not mistaken so he does have some
idea of the pawn
structure which i think is actually very
important at this level
yes exactly to be able to make progress
with uh with pawns all right she takes
and he takes back it could be a weakness
but open rook
maybe center reinforced
um he's gotta not be so down on himself
like he's gonna hang b5 he's not gonna
see that but he needs to play
knight d6 just keep it cool
okay good so far no she's gonna see this
probably
maybe maybe she'll play queen f6 that's
also like a
aggressive move yeah i think so far myth
has a great position i think when i look
at the position that he has
it's um it's about as good of a position
as he could get he's castled
he's developed nothing really is under
attack
so we're in a stage where both players
have to come up with plans and i think
that trying to come up with plans here
this is the first step
um in terms of trying to uh win the game
you have to be able to get out of the
opening stage counselor can develop
and then worry about coming up with
long-term plans but if you can't get out
of the opening stage like in the
previous game that myth had
um that's you're going to lose very
early and even for xqc we saw it um
you know against charlie and a couple of
other matches where if he didn't get out
of the opening
stage he would just lose right away so
it is very very critical
um and i think in terms of myth he
should try to come up with this idea
like bishop c2 and queen d3 and line up
the battery towards pokemon's king
yes something over here it's a game
filled with different ideas uh but it
can be difficult i mean it could be
difficult to stack it all together
because just the kind of thing like
bishop c2 only makes sense if you
combine it with other moves
otherwise you're never going to play it
and you know you might just take on d6
because it's like
an option and then you have to find
something else you can't just trade
everybody all the time um
we'll see what he comes up with it's a
big moment
i'm i'm pumped for myth rookie one okay
good move by myth i i like what he's
doing if he doesn't make blunders i
think um
i think i think that's the other thing
if you don't give up like bishops or
knights for free
uh then then you have much better
chances so as long as you miss the
obvious blunders you're you're looking
good and i think myth has a great
position so far uh which is why i bet
bet on him okay bishop g4 again he needs
to not panic keep it cool
h3 and then she has to go bishop h5 and
then keep the attention
i would love to actually you know it's
not the best move but i'd love to see
miss play d5 here
and line up that uh that pin on the
diagonal and i think pokeman sees it
did you see the way pokemon her eyebrows
popped up i think she saw d5 was a move
maybe now i wish we saw the uh the
screener had the
had the the mic but we don't sadly but
that's all right
um and you know i was also thinking one
other thing that's really amazing is
you'll see that a lot of these a lot of
these players i think maybe it's just
more competitive they are
but when they make a mistake you'll see
these expressions like benji yesterday
i mean he kept it together but you could
totally tell that when he started the
first game against negrano started to
slip away
he wanted to rage you could just see
that he was that passion that
into it um i think seeing the
expressions from from quite a few of
these players is uh
it's really amazing yeah they they want
it
you know and they've been working and it
sucks because sometimes you put in a lot
of work and it
all of i i've said this i would hate to
learn chess as an adult because i
don't know how difficult it would be
i've tried to learn other things like
it's
it's it's so tough and it can be very
frustrating so you've got to be ready to
make a lot of mistakes and lose a lot
because a lot of us want to be efficient
with our learning we want to do well
but you are going to lose so much more
in the beginning before
before you're going to win so well i
mean i think that's why chess is that's
also why chess is such a great game
because
you have that learning curve and it's
such a long process i think in many ways
it teaches you
how to learn and how kind of how to lose
and how to persevere and overcome it
and um sort of find that motivation
within yourself
and i think xqc oh no oh no
no no no no what does she think about
three
yeah i know when pokeman sees that you
can just tell the way she put her
fingers together that was also another
tale
telltale sign you can tell that she
could tell something was wrong with that
yeah i i wish i was uh the barrier oh
no just just that expression you could
tell she sensed that something was wrong
there
shout out to all those working hard both
on and off the camera to make chess more
enjoyable and amazing for the fans and
the participants that's out of the
personal account
not the company account by the way just
in case anybody
you know uh danny hope you're good
thanks for letting me sub in for you
today uh i wish i was bringing that news
at a better moment danny could not have
picked a more
tense moment here oh man and brutal
at least he goes king f1 though he's
going to run the king to the center
yes um yeah but this is really harsh
really difficult situation here for myth
his king is under attack
doesn't really have any counter play
it's like basically the texture of the
position with all these pieces
they're no attacks for white and black
has all the ideas and i think in general
when you end up in such situations it's
very very hard to play yeah i wonder if
i i actually have a feeling if anybody
in the event pokey is the most cerebral
who would just make a draw
because she knows that she wins like i
don't know she just she seems like she
kind of works out the details
she'll play queen h2 if she needs to and
she'll repeat if she needs to but we'll
see she might just
be confident that she will find queen h2
and uh with the next move
um however if she does not find queen
shoe and myth can play rook to h1 the
game could swing very quickly because
even though myth is behind by a pawn um
actually queen h4 my queen h4 is
actually a better move so king e2
there's knight takes deep
does she see that i don't know if she
sees it but queen h4 is the best move
objectively
because now you can't run with the king
on queen h3 if you go king f1 king e2
king d3
um so queen h4 is actually the best move
here
just objectively the best move and i do
think there is a good chance that
pokemon will actually realize that she
also you can see a slight sort of smile
on her face as well
and that kind of told me that she has
some idea there's some way to maybe
finish this match very quickly here
like queen g5 or rookie six are both
very strong
i mean she she uh also i think is
experienced enough to know the concept
of the rook lift if she just plays
rookie six
wow yeah better than ludwig what can i
say
ludwig i mean in that moment against
charlie couldn't find it but here's
pokemane
yeah and he had two a little bit harder
and finding finding the rook lifts
and by the way the rook h6 and rook d5
there so
um no rookie six is very clean and
this is over in a move if rook h1 rook
g6
yeah you know i mean i think this is the
thing uh i i
i don't think we've seen it because i
don't think pokeman has been been
playing chess or studying chess on
stream but to me it's very clear that
she has been putting a lot of time
because
these concepts like rookie six rook g6
just not it's just not a normal concept
to find and takes time and
even someone like ludwig who has put in
a lot of time um
uh studying the game like even that it's
just if you if you haven't seen it it
doesn't come right away then um
it's very hard and for everybody who's
wondering no they're i mean there is no
there
there's everyone wants to create some
magic beef with ludwig there is no magic
beef
um only magic beef is there's a waffle
beef right but there's no magic beef
um no there's no magic beef but uh
there's uh there's wagyu and that's
pretty damn close
so no but i mean that's that's my new
business idea
i'm gonna create a new brand uh magic
beef there's already impossible beef or
impossible meat or whatever and beyond
meat i just
create magic meat that's all that either
sounds terrifying or like the next
billion dollar company
like i'm gonna see it go public your
your stock ticker will be beef
and it's i don't know if that probably
exists already but
what a meme ticker anyway all right okay
um yeah
okay okay she plays queen g5 she did
have rook g6 and that was lights out
so but it's not over now it's not oh
queen e3 never mind
did she see that i mean this is just so
brutal it's so
i think the thing that's really been
frustrating or difficult to watch with
myth
is that he ended up in a group where he
was he was clearly or it was over match
he was in the group of death with three
very strong players
and so you know when i look at like
rubius for example who he actually
finally got a win today even though he
lost niko
he could have won any one of those games
and with myth it just feels like he's
been really unlucky
and out of all the games he's played
he's the one player who i feel like has
unfortunately not had any any any legit
or realistic winning chance at any of
the games so it's very very difficult um
and i feel bad for men
yeah it's tough because to be honest the
growth that he's that he's shown
in a month's time it's very similar to
michelle like michelle's like 500.
and that's fine the problem is
you have a brutal field man you have
people who just
maybe put in 10 more hours than you and
that makes all the difference in those
10 hours they got
10 different tactical situations and
they find themselves more confident
yeah no it's definitely true um
and it's just yeah it's pretty it's
pretty tough to see here i feel really
bad for myth just very unlucky with the
groups
now pokeyman plays queen takes pawn i
was going to say the one thing i would
say about pokemane
is i think in her group it's not going
to be that big of an issue
um but she seems to have this
predilection towards trying to trade
down when she's ahead by one or two
pawns
um and i think that in this this this
sort of this this match and probably
this bracket won't matter but sometimes
you really do have to go for the kill
you cannot be so materialistic and just
try to grab
pawns and trade it all down
yeah i totally agree and right right now
is a good chance for myth to play a move
like queen c2
but tough to see that right
you got definitely very very difficult
um to see
and then he's gotta hope pokey does what
she did against xqc that was so
so rough to watch because she had it
oh but he's lining it up even if it's
not c2 it's a great idea lining up the
checkmate and
again pokemon with the obvious tell you
can you can see how she's looking she's
like
what is what's going on here what is the
idea and unfortunately because it's such
a weird move i think it's pretty obvious
what the idea is on h7
okay well she blunders it okay it's
still winning
for pokeman yeah wow that's actually
lucky i mean if she had moved the other
rook
over it would have been mate like
damn she's gotta go here unfortunately
the white king is still too open here so
pokeman should find a checkmate
um but that being said at least smith
gets something and i think
come on yeah i'm happy i'm the one
checking
phil's like yeah guys take the bishop
you go straight ahead go take it
oh you want another one
i like it yeah would you look at that as
two
i could play this game too
take the rook come on
all right come on don't take the pawn
there's a rook on the other side i like
queen h4 just for the
yes just for the idea of making a check
and hoping that pokemon won't see it
uh to be honest no don't touch your rook
no don't touch your rook please don't
touch the rook on a1 please just move
your queen
yeah he's um okay good he finally sees
it
so i actually could see he he actually
clicked on the rook on a1 when he was
almost like going to play rook d1 so at
least he takes the rook
yes they do this thing mm-hmm they do
this thing they tickle the pieces and
i'm just like all right take the
no don't touch the rick and then i'm
like okay okay yeah pokey's gotta
check him she's gotta change it's all
it's all good um unless you unless
you're xqc where like you automatically
your first instinct is the right one you
click the right piece
you got the right move and then you
start clicking all over the place and
becoming a
you know doubting uh daniel
what kind of a name would be best
associated with a doubter
doug i don't know doug
i'm not every doug i've ever met i i
didn't really i hope i'm not like
forgetting i i i i mean you're supposed
to say aren't you supposed to use the
same letter
well yeah doug what's wrong with her
doubting doug go here take the pawn yeah
i don't know douglas doubting donald
trump human is a douglas doubting drake
i don't know but anyway
we'll see what happens yes queenie two
is literally made i love how hype myth
is he has no idea of
oh and she takes on b2 see this is what
i'm saying she gets way too
materialistic when she sees something
she like this is the second game she's
probably gonna win anyway
but she's way too materialistic in
situations where
um where it's not required like she
doesn't go for the checkmate she doesn't
go for the kill she doesn't look for the
checks immediately
um in kind of the way that i i think
she's good which it's it's
it's like in the first game it didn't
matter because she won anyone we need to
take out this night
trying to trade down taking the pawns a
couple of pawns in this game really
unnecessary
yes right now it might still go in her
favor
but oh all right uh
oh oh oh no but now this invites queenie
two now queenie she should see queenie
two because it's a
it's a check um it's a tactic puzzle yes
uh if she takes a2 i i would not be
shocked if she takes a2 as well
but i think she kind of has to realize
she is behind here material
uh myth has two rooks on the board and
she only has a rook and a night so i
think because of that
she should look for it but again that's
what i'm saying she goes queen takes
pawn
um getting way too materialistic not
looking for chucks
and as the saying goes you miss 100 of
the checks that you don't you don't you
don't make
if you don't check you can never check
me i don't know if she if she's
lucky or brilliant but queen d8 is made
if the night isn't there
so exactly yep oh wait like walking on
on a tight rope and like if she moves
the night now thinking it's hanging if
she does not look at queenie two
mm-hmm just looking if she doesn't look
for checks it's very very dangerous
it's it's it isn't she mated on queensy
seven like king of
maybe not almost almost definitely very
very close here
she has to find the check and she hasn't
found one in like
seven moves so yikes
and they've been there she's just not
looking for them she's just picking up
pawns but they're not relevant the king
is relevant the rooks are relevant
gotta go for a check
dense moment here she doesn't give a
check she might straight up lose
yeah i think i think there's a good
chance she will lose if she does not
make a check here
because all myth wants is c7 it's insane
and she
finds it wow but is she going to take
the rook or she going to make it what i
didn't see before
so it's kind of 50 50 when she went
rookie six idea was to make a check so
we'll kind of see
um what happens i would guess she takes
the rook
but yeah yeah i mean
she would take the rook uh because it's
just it's an obvious free rook and you
know the rooks and the queens are really
really worth a lot
yeah the rook maneuver
at this point is decisive again she
needs to just spot it and she'll be okay
but okay there it is
rookie two
myth smith has two legal moves so
there it is and now you take the rook
yes and that she's gonna spot because
she's been snap taking rooks
yeah uh was that a pre-move maybe maybe
he wants to move against queen d6
check and play f4
i don't know that was very strange but
anyway at any rate um
uh myth cannot win he only has one queen
he can make a lot of checks with the
queen but
there's no way he's getting a check made
here with a lone queen on the board
um yeah she has a queen she has a rook
uh okay queen f1 i don't love is there
any outside way that white can make a
checkmate
here with the queen of the pond is what
i'm trying to figure out
somehow the rook covers everything
important you know
it's like just covering all the right
spots
the other thing i would say the reason
that pokemon will win here will not lose
this game either is she does know the
concept of trading down
she knows how to make some of the basic
checkmates like the king and queen
versus king she has that memorized
king and rook as well like she's got
some of these basic mates down so
one thing that pokeman is very good at
and it's something i've noticed like
sardosh and benji also do very well and
it's one of these characteristics is
they do not get tunnel vision like if
they know there's a forest way to win a
certain setup
they will go for it every time they will
ignore the other half of the board if
they
if they can and they'll just know the
technique so it is one thing that pokey
um
pokey does very well so that's why i do
think she is not in any danger
i'm in this position
yeah that check is a bit annoying
because you already look at the time
look at the time that's the only thing
myth has
he's got a queen and time and that's
that that's his pr oh oh
yikes okay queen takes knight
uh don't go don't keep don't keep going
forward you just go okay she goes back
and there's no back there's no ice
skater because even if you go to f8 or
f8 dude
this is terrifying like yeah it's almost
like there's no checkmate because white
would need to get the queen to g5
oh my gosh pokemon it's just copy still
it's not checkmate still i know king e4
is still not
made but you don't go forward oh
my it's wait how is it a draw exactly
there's probably some repetition here
with like queen c4 queen c3 c4
you can check on c4 c3 and if f5 you go
f7 c4 you do the yoyo
oh yo-yo between f7 c4 and c4 c3 it's
just a classic yo-yo
and it's like the yo-yo where you uh
what do you call it i don't know what
you call where did that even come from
yo-yo
around the moon i don't know anyway
whatever um it just
said yo-yo yeah because it's a yo-yo you
see it's like
one end up back i know yeah it's not
like
you're right i used to play the yo-yo
but i don't know what you call that that
anyway whatever okay is that an xqc
thing or you just made that up i just
made that
all back beautiful beautiful okay you
made that out sorry
you we just witnessed history you are
the first grand master to ever call a
maneuver like that a yo-yo
so it's uh but myth takes mitt doesn't
realize that he's in grave danger the
scissor
or the ladder sorry check on g2 and go
queen h1
yeah um it's time for essentially one
also yeah
you see is it
oh wait all the ambulance
okay why'd you you got us all the way
over here for this
well she she really got my hopes up you
know that
i that's so disrespectful dude that is
so rude
she really did she really she's like you
know what let's play this whole thing
out dude
let's play this whole thing out so i can
make him feel like he has a chance
just so i can take it all away from him
at the very end this is cyberbullying
i can't believe it
i know i know
it's made
oh i was sweating at the end there
i won't lie that was
very very intense pokey
pokey gets the win that first one was
mildly less stressful than this one this
one yeah this one got really spicy at
the end
yeah that was uh that was crazy
but she does take the win we're going to
get the players to join us on call for
our final interview of the day
park champs 3 presented by grip6 it's
our final break we'll be right back
oh well that was a good one that was a
good one
boys well i wanted to review the chess
games that we had yet to uh
review because we never got a chance to
but i think i have something more fun we
could review
have you guys heard of the game rocket
league
there it is there it is
makes it look like he's lost control now
if you guys haven't
um this is what i was doing this morning
when i was preparing for uh logic
ex i think he car roasted me earlier but
i was i was playing a bit of a of rocket
league because i had a show match
versus atrial for 1250
um match of the century atriac the ankle
snatch reverse a lot of the small
um let's just skip ahead here what we've
seen so far is is really
really incredible let's just skip a
little bit further ahead
oh one zero me i'm the blue side
kind of a laser
now you might be wondering ludwig i
thought it was supposed to be like an
even match
what ended up happening well i'm going
to show you this unreleased footage
because i did a local recording
during all of this this is the funniest
part
when i was playing atriac earlier today
in that exact moment that we were just
looking at
for those first three goals
one second the video's auto rewinding
and i don't know why
why does the video auto rewind uh anyway
the point is though
oh it's because my controller's plugged
in
so i had a problem with my controller
that you just saw the lb button is
automatically pressed
so the scoreboard was open for the
entire first three goals
oh my god that was stressful let's try
and uh and i still went 3-0 on him
how is he so bad
and i wasn't sure if it was the game or
not so i opened up the discord and
asked if it was the real game what's
going on
is he [ __ ] with me
he this is the real game
anyway it was 12-1 at the end of it uh
which is a new record
for both of us in the biggest blowout
ever in the smug
playoff match so shout out to us boys
shout out to us we have the world record
now
surely we'll have to put that on youtube
during break
anyway
game two i did not use my boost at all
then game three i didn't use a jump
that is true i figured it would be
weird to just 12-1 stomp your homie
better swag on him than tell in front of
30 000 people
welcome back everyone to our final
interview of the day joined by both
players
congratulations obviously uh pokey how
uh how did that match go
expectations versus reality how was that
um to be honest
i have not been practicing enough chess
and my chest vision was quite off today
that's why i had to
keep putting on the goggles
[Music]
thought that was trash um we thought you
were like
we thought you were like zero oh no no
that's me like
looking for the right move you know
that's what i was missing
yeah i'll open up my goggles next time
don't worry
thanks but yeah i think it went i mean
i'm glad i won
but myth has been practicing pretty well
he could have taken it for sure
but you know i got like 200 rating on
him so i need to win right
that's the expectation i mean yeah we've
had uh
we've had all sorts of crazy matches so
rating hasn't always
but yes i mean i guess going in uh you
would be the favorite myth
um we he speak speaking of you know
favorites we were saying you were in the
group of death in the group in the early
stage right like did you feel that way
how did that how's your chest been since
you
kind of kicked this whole process off in
january uh up to now
the group of the group of death yeah we
thought that it was kind of insane with
sardosh and benji
and um overall like
i've just been having a great time
playing chess uh i don't think i've
put in as much time as i would uh have
liked to
overall there's a lot of things to work
on and
to uh for me to do but overall like i
think this has been
a really great introduction to chess and
i'm excited to like
keep at it you know and i think that's
the important thing that i'm getting out
of this
is like you know i've become interested
in this game
because of this event and because of you
know
just the excitement around versing some
of you know some people like pokey and
and nico and benji and just the hype all
around it so i definitely
want to you know move forward with it
which i think
you know that's that's important for me
well hicaro we were uh
we're kind of alluding to that right i
mean specifically just the practice and
the behind the scenes and how each
creator has to balance it pokey
how much practice are you were you still
doing
off stream behind the scenes like if you
without giving away prep
because you're still in the event right
so yeah i prior to
actual matches i'll usually do like uh
a small coaching sesh but to be honest i
haven't been actually
playing a lot or getting that experience
which i think
if anything is probably the most
important thing um but i also don't want
to like stress myself you must play
three hours of chess every day
i'm just glad that i think you know i'll
get better with time i think myth did
really really well and as he said i'm
just glad to feel like i kind of
picked it up as a hobby hopefully for
life yeah
hopefully for life indeed takara any uh
any any anyone
i just want to say i think in in terms
of myth uh like when we said group of
death like the reason for saying that is
that three of the players who were in
your original group stage
two of them are probably gonna i mean
they're probably the favorites to me in
the final the champions bracket
nico has played ex extremely well and
she's had a lot of experience so we felt
that perhaps
uh you didn't really have opportunities
in the way that you would have if you
were in other groups and then
um and then today was it was a struggle
too but but overall i thought you had
some opportunities you played wellness
match today
and you just keep your head up and um
and if you just play even if it's just
casually you will improve so i think
that's that's sort of
what i would say is don't be discouraged
by what has happened
newbie group next time and it's me and
myth in it
yup straight to the top
yeah but uh no yeah for sure this is
it's been extremely like motivating and
even like
playing against these like i guess like
the juggernaut players and the group
and still being able to like you know
make some things happen or it being like
me just not seeing one move
to it being like a really really close
match or like me getting even ahead just
off of missing one move
is really like obviously it could be
really the motivating but it's something
to learn from and it's uh it's
motivating also
in the same exact way so i want to keep
it up
well thank you both
you keep referring to like the newbie
group or or not having expectations
now uh you probably are one of the
favorites to potentially make to the
final at least the consolation bracket i
was curious you you mentioned um
in a previous interview that hoffo had
been cheering you on i was wondering
um like has she been giving you advice
has it just been like just good luck uh
what what what have she kind of said to
you if you don't mind sharing that
honestly just always being really
supportive cheering me on she also
introduced me to
someone who helped her gm hess and he
has been just like
so helpful um doing some like small
coaching sessions off stream and just
also helping me have the right attitude
towards the games
you know i'm here for a good time not a
long time so yeah
yeah honestly on that note if either of
you ever wants to get like
hyped up or like pumped up and motivated
back up in the vaude
and watch what logic said because like
he said the most
inspirational like five minutes it was
it was it was amazing he's like
i'm gonna get off this call and you know
i'm gonna go back to you know my wife
and kid
uh you know whatever whatever grind it
is that you're on just go right back to
it
and you're here like you said for a good
time not a long time so but pokey on
that note you probably want to win it
now right because you
keep on winning now in this consolation
bracket so you're we'll see
well um thank you to you both of you
for the match uh myth hope to see you
playing chess on stream in the future
and pokey will see you for the semis
thank you for having us have a good one
bye guys
we uh we're gonna end the day with what
our
consolation bracket looks like we've
only got two because we're still waiting
for
tubbo and code miko and then in two days
we have beast and michelle and we
probably have that in two days because
of the scheduling of everything but also
maybe beast is in the mountains
somewhere filming i'm sure mr beast is
probably
recording his next big you know
multi-million dollar uh
video probably uh which will get you
know the classic 50 million views on
youtube so i'm sure he's very he's a
very busy guy
um and uh it's going to be exciting
though because i think that's a pretty
balanced matchup between
mr beast and michelle carrie i think it
could go either way jimmy has had his
moments where he's won some games he's
also had some
unfortunate moments as well michelle she
played really well against rayne wilson
who's still in the championship bracket
so she could win two
it's gonna be a very exciting match of
course tomorrow we have taboo against
code miko
which should be exciting as well on that
note we're going to take just one final
look at the champions bracket
and you know higher that's kind of crazy
these guys have two days to prep they
got tomorrow and friday
like that's more than more than some
gm's get you guys get a game a day off
so i hope we see some fire prep
i hope we see uh you know yeah i think i
mean in terms of consolation bracket
it's just players should just work on
the things that they're they're missing
and i think like in pokeman's case she's
a little bit too materialistic at times
instead of looking to sort of attack and
chuck made her opponent's king um that
could just be a defensive reflex
uh but i think like mr beast he he when
he got out of the opening with good
positions
he was doing very well in all of his
games even against ludwig so i think for
him the opening should be his priority
just try to get out get to like move 10
um and go from there and michelle i
think just keep grinding she got some
great positions against rayne
um and and she's she's been trying very
hard so i think she's uh she's
she has a great chance as well but it'll
be exciting to watch
yeah tomorrow uh we we already know that
matchup that's kind of the uh the final
sign-off moment
it was uh it's been an intense day of
games i mean it yeah it's
it's been crazy i mean i think we saw
charlie
i mean he was the winner of the
consolation bracket yeah one put up a
great fight against rain but came
a little bit short um very tense match i
think the logic ludwig
match also really really close one one
the the final blitz game
logic missed the mate and two ludwig
ends up with it ends up going around the
other way and then he has his mate in
two
right away so really really exciting
pokemon myth as well
um and there was one other match right
was it
what was the other one there was a
fourth one i'm blanking it's been a long
day i'm forgetting uh well no
there was nikko and rubius in the
morning that was the other one right
which also
um very very close match that could have
been uh that could have been
or no it was one one right it was one
more it was nico
that also went to a blitz game so really
really intense matches
all around and i think the fact that
we're seeing these close matches no real
mismatches especially the fact that it's
been so competitive has been
really the biggest change i think in
pogchamps three versus the other pog
champs uh where
it's really close everyone is trying
really really hard and it's been
a lot of fun to watch so far and it's
only going to get more intense as we
reach the semis and then the
finals as well it's been uh
it's been awesome oh my uh sorry my uh
my camera died because i booted up uh
i booted up obs that's that's that's
that's what happens oh
are you streaming that's why yeah yeah
yeah so i'm gonna be i've got the
raid to yourself yep yes exactly uh
it's it's not me it's the mods but uh
listen
just a shout out to chat uh shout out to
all the you know
commentators on earlier today everybody
working behind the scenes to make this
uh event so awesome and uh we'll see you
back tomorrow for just one match-up
just one matchup and that's uh that's
tubbo versus uh code miko
park champ three presented by grip six
we out
bye
[Music]
three two one
[Music]
black
[Music]
three two one here we go
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
get out take it out
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
oh